Earth's diverse
continents home to millions of species
of animals who clash in Nature's Savage
battles of
survival but what happens when these
terrestrial Titans turn against each
[Music]
other animals fight tooth and Claw to
win food territory and right to the
bloodline from The Plains of Africa to
the ice of the Arctic there are no
ruins this is Animal Fight
Night on the African Savannah the fight
for life is brutal and relentless
in this blood soaked Arena two
Gladiators stand out from the
competition in one corner weighing in at
around 550 lbs the lion is pure
Swagger with the chops to back it
up running at up to 50 mph it uses brute
force and a set of Razor are sharp claws
to take down any animal that wets its
appetite in the other Corner weighing up
to a staggering 2,200 lb the Nile
crocodile is a deadly armored
assassin a ruthless Predator who uses
one of the most forceful bites on Earth
to drag animals as big as a wilderbeast
to a grim underwater
death but when these two two super
Predators face
off all bets are
off the banks of the mara River Kenya a
pack of Crocs beast on a dead
hippo a pride of hungry Lions
Approach at 3,000 lb a hippo is a big
prize and this lion is detered
determined to steal
some he swipes with his deadly
Claws and signals his intentions with an
ear shattering
Roar the Lion's larynx is set far back
in his
throat where most other animals have a
bone he has an elastic ligament that
stretches to 8 in creating a wide air
passage that amplifies his Roar to 114
DB
as loud as a jet engine taking off it
can be heard 5 miles
away it would scare off a lesser
opponent but it'll take more than that
to impress a Nile crocodile because the
Nile Croc has a killer weapon a powerful
set of
Jaws he has seven jaw muscles just one
is for opening the other six are
dedicated to clamping shut creating a
bite force of almost 3,000
lb you'd need a hydraulic press to pry
them
open but the pride has a
strategy the male lions work as
bodyguards while a lionist moves in to
feed she knows not to venture too close
to the
[Music]
Crocs instead she stays Shor side and
uses her sharp back teeth like scissors
to Shear flesh off the dead hippo's
leg but the male lions decide they want
the whole Beast and the situation
escalates 1 and 1/2 in claws are as
sharp as a knife and can easily slice
most animals skin and
muscle but the Croc has
armor a geometric arrangement of scales
that allows him free movement and
protection at the same
time the lionist puts it to the
test but his armor holds
he
bites but her reflexes are too
fast the Crocs won't back
down but neither will the
Lions so they both settle in for dinner
with a side dish of
danger tooth versus Claw is nothing
compared to the biggest fight of all
with trunks killer tusks and 10 tons of
Savannah
combat standing up to 13 ft tall
elephants are the strongest animals to
walk the
earth easily pushing over anything that
gets in their
way no other animal could dream of
taking on a grown
elephant apart from another
elephant these behemoths need to quench
their thirst every 3 days but out here
in the Kalahari Desert water is scarce
so when a precious life-giving pool is
discovered elephants from over 100 miles
around
descend elephants are social animals but
their social hierarchy is in
flux the adult males must fight for
dominance and mating
rights fights can be epic ending with
one of the contenders
dead this is the big daddy he's 27 years
old and used to getting his
way but his Challenger is defiant and
itching for a
fight big daddy is the first to
attack he tests the Challenger's
strength the name of the game is to push
your opponent over using one of the most
formidable weapons in the animal kingdom
Big Daddy's trunk is a fusion of his
upper lip and nose containing around
100,000 different
muscles this makes it maneuverable and
strong a lethal combination like no
other the Challenger uses his to try to
force Big Daddy
down but here in the water neither side
can land a decisive
blow time to take the fight onto Solid
[Music]
Ground Big Daddy tries to spear his
opponent with his killer weapon
tusks his tusks are actually long teeth
made from dentine with an enamel coating
that makes them incredibly hard they're
so strong they can Pierce hide that's up
to 1 in
thick the Challenger strikes back with
his tusks to force Big Daddy's head down
just like humans are left or
right-handed elephants have a dominant
Tusk he twists to take advantage of his
he tries to jump to get more height on
Big
Daddy but the move
backfires big daddy now has leverage
under the Challenger's
trunk his tusks are dangerously close to
the Challenger
Underside the Challenger's chest and rib
cage is where he's most
vulnerable if Big Daddy's Tusk pierces
here it could hit the Challenger's
Airways lungs her heart leaving him
mortally
[Music]
injured the Challenger knows he's in
trouble and turns to
disengage but it's a critical error and
Big Daddy presses home his
advantage it's a winning
move the humiliated Challenger
flees leaving Big Daddy as king of the
watering
hole when it comes to combat big isn't
always
best these creatures are so ferocious
they'll fight to the death
battling on even after they've been
decapitated in Africa even the smallest
animals have to fight for their right to
survive as an colonies grow they need
more and more
food the fastest way to secure it is a
violent takeover of their neighbors's
land with two armies both more than
10,000 strong this battle will have a
high body
count any ant Warrior that takes the
field may not make it home
alive the inch long soldiers lead the
attack they send out pheromones for
others to join join
them African ants have a heart-shaped
head equipped with their major weapon
the
mandibles ant mandibles are curved with
a jagged edge like a
saw they're made of kiten the same as
their exoskeleton but are reinforced
with proteins that make them even
stronger to cut through the bodies of
their
enemies
using their mandibles the ants locked
together with all their
might their goal rip off their rival's
limbs and Target the vulnerable area
between the head and
chest and they work together to take out
their
opposition the ant on the right uses her
mandibles to hold her opponent down
while the ant on the left tries to saw
her head
[Music]
off these are one of animal fight
night's ultimate
contenders because even if they do
succeed in severing a rival's body part
just like in a zombie movie The
incomplete body can keep on
fighting
this ant is fighting against a head and
an arm that has been severed from its
body ants have a simple nervous system
their basic movements are controlled by
bundles of nerves called ganglia spread
out along their bodies when an ant loses
a head or other body part the ganglia
continue to generate
movement this disembodied head can fight
on for hours or until its body fluid
runs
out the fight won't be over until every
last ounce of energy has been
spent as the battlefield becomes
littered with the dying body parts of
the
Defenders it becomes clear the Invaders
have won a Grizzly
Victory their territory and food supply
has just gotten a whole lot bigger
you may sometimes think males have only
one thing on their
mind and for Red Deer Stags during the
rut or breeding season you'd be
absolutely
[Music]
right Red Deer Stags spend so much
energy chasing girls that at the end of
the rut they can drop down Dead with
exhaustion most of that energy is used
up fighting off the
competition this Casanova is 7 years
old 4 1/2 ft tall and weighing up to 418
lbs he's at his Peak reproductive
Fitness casanova's got himself a Harum
of female
deer now all he has to do is hold on to
them this is his love rival
pumped full of testosterone and ready to
fight he calls out a
challenge Casanova
replies he won't give up his females
without a fight the prize is the right
to the
bloodline but stag fights can end in
injury and death so both Fighters risk
losing it
all both Warriors deploy their key off
offensive
weapon they're
antlers driving them into their opponent
using all of their body
weight the strategy is lock push then
twist trying to throw your opponent off
balance and turn his body so you can
Gore him with the sharp
points antlers are made of bone Stags
strip the minerals from their own
skeleton so they can grow them up to 39
in Long
flexible and tough they can be used to
inflict deep wounds put out an eye and
even kill by puncturing an opponent's
skull but they've got to get past their
Rivals adlers
first shaped like a catcher SM they're
as good defensively as they are
offensively the Challenger tries to get
the advantage by twisting ing his
antlers from
below but he's thrown off
balance he rallies quickly enough to
avoid being gored and tries
again he drives kasanova back the tips
of his antlers are desperately close to
casanova's vulnerable eyes
and his
skull way too close for casanova's
liking keep fighting and he risks
death so he chooses
life and his love rival claims his
herum at least until the next Challenger
Stakes his
claim
in the Arctic the polar bear is the
resident
Kingpin he can walk for days in this
snowbound Wilderness without meeting
another living
being which suits him just
fine it's when he meets another polar
bear that the problems
start
with female polar bears only having Cubs
once every 2 or 3 years there are many
more males than available females and
the competition for the right to breed
is
Cutthroat so male polar bears have
evolved to be Warriors up to 10 ft tall
and weighing 1500 lb they're double the
size of the females and have bigger
weapons
too fights often end in both animals
being bloodied and M so when two male
polar bears meet the results can be
brutal the frozen Arctic nature at its
most beautiful and it's most
merciless two of the largest land
carnivores on Earth Clash over the
rights to the
bloodline on the right at 10 years of
age this bear is older and battle
scarred but on the left the 8-year-old
Junior has seen his share of fighting
too with the missing chunks of fur to
prove
it polar bears fight like sumo wrestlers
pushing their opponents to try to get
them off balance and send them crashing
to the
ground the older bear launches a volley
of powerful attacks on his younger
opponent his for limbs are designed for
strength the muscles attached to the
bones further away from the pivoting
joints than they do in other animals
producing more
leverage giving him a more powerful
punch than a grizzly
bear the old bear uses his hind limb
muscles to launch his entire 1500lb body
down on his
opponent that's like having two vending
machines dropped on your
head but the young Challenger is
tough he battles to get his p on top to
dominate his
opponent the Challenger has five curved
2-in claws on each paw sharp and strong
enough to cut through ice they can
inflict serious damage on another
bear then Junior brings out his best
weapon his
teeth he aims for the older Bear's
exposed neck
the Challenger has 42 teeth including
four canines up to 2 in long their
length means he can sink them deep into
his opponent before clamping down with a
force of almost 500
lb but the veterans got a deadly set of
teeth
too he bites back getting a hold on the
Challenger's neck
and when his attacks become
Relentless the Challenger cuts his
losses he doesn't want any more chunks
taken out of his neck
today when you think of animal action
heroes a gecko might not be the first
thing that Springs to
mind he may only be a few inches long
but he can scale a a sheer rock face
shed his skin to get out of a tight
corner and make himself almost totally
invisible this is a 3-year-old walberg's
velvet
gecko he's locked in Mortal Kombat with
a 5-year-old Western Nal green
snake it grows up to 51 in
Long 11 times is the gecko
size the snake wants to eat
him but this action heroes determined he
won't be on the menu
today the gecko is a season Warrior he's
already lost his tail in a previous
battle in this fight he has a bold but
simple
strategy bite and hold the snake's jaw
that way his oppon opponent can't eat
him it's a risky
tactic the snake strategy is to bite the
gecko
repeatedly delivering a Venom that will
cause the gecko to Hemorrhage blood
until he's so exhausted the snake can
devour him
whole although the gecko's hold prevents
the snake eating him he can still bite
and deliver Venom but the gecko has a
defense he can close off the blood
supply to his broken skin
and here on this log he can bring
another skill into play adhesive
feet up to 100 million grippers on each
foot generate around 4 and 1/2 lb of
sticking Force meaning he can cling to
the log even though the snake is pulling
against him with all his
power but the gecko's jaw can't hold
forever he gets the upper hand again
but the snake bites have cut so deep his
constricting blood vessels are
[Music]
useless the snake goes for the gecko's
back and
sides but he can't get a
hold the gecko's strategy of biting and
holding on for all he's worth is working
[Music]
again and the snakes had enough
the geckos put up too tough a
fight he enjoys Victory and none too
soon when geckos fight their oxygen
needs far out strip Supply and lactic
acid builds up in their
bodies this fight has been the
equivalent of running a
marathon at least he's
alive but then the snake changes his
mind real life isn't like the movies the
hero doesn't always
win and the snake gets his
reward he devours his dinner
whole
life and death battles don't just happen
on
land down here they involve teeth Venom
and one very big
[Music]
mouth the Pacific coast California
a paradise of sun Sand and
Surf but beneath the waves it's a
Battleground because this stretch of
sunny California is home to the most
argumentative fish in the
sea the sarcastic Fringe
head a foot long fish
with
Attitude home can be anything from a
crack in a rock to an old Tin Can for
this old man of the sea it's an
abandoned
shell a sarcastic Fringe head's home is
his castle become homeless and he'll be
vulnerable to predators and struggle to
find food to eat he'll defend it with
all he's
got
so when an octopus crosses his land
looking for
food an underwater Showdown is
[Music]
inevitable The Fringe head goes on the
attack his weapon a mouth that flares
wide to reveal 75 razor sharp teeth his
goal sink those deadly little knives
into the octopus's soft
flesh but that won't be
easy this octopus is young but already
battle
scarred with a short stump where one of
his arms should be perhaps he's met a
sarcastic Fringe head
before his remaining arms are up to
twice as long as his opponent so so he
packs a serious
punch each arm has two or 300
suckers if he catches the fish he can
use these to pull it to his sharp beak
where he'll deliver a dose of poison so
deadly a single drop can paralyze a
small
fish but the old man is
agile a flexible body and large bendy
fins mean he's built for swimming in
quick
bursts and can change direction in an
instant in this fight speed and
unpredictability are an
advantage the octopus lands a couple of
punches and while he's got some
Breathing Room takes the chance to
escape the old man gets in one last
vicious attack as he
Retreats just to make sure the Intruder
never darkens his door
again the sarcastic Fringe head gets his
prize
lunch and a peaceful
home across the world animals fight to
get enough food to
survive and on the African Savannah
everybody else's lunch is fair
game
wild dogs weigh up to 79
lb and can reach a top speed of 37
mph at least 70% of their hunts end in a
kill and pound for pound they eat more
than any other
carnivore weighing in at up to 176 lb a
Hy Ena can hear the sound of a kill up
to 6 M away and smell it from 2 and
A2 it will take on a pride of lions if
it thinks there's food to be
had in Krueger National Park a pack of
wild dogs devour an Impala at well over
100 lb it will keep the whole pack going
for a
day but sure enough it's not long before
competition
arrives two hyenas want a piece of the
action but the dogs won't give up their
kill without a
fight and with both animals able to kill
each other this fight could end with
dead prey and
[Music]
Predator Krueger National Park South
Africa two hyenas fight with eight wild
dogs over a dead Impala the hyenas are
twice the dog size but the dogs work as
a pack using a range of sounds including
these twitters to talk to each
other they use their Collective muscle
to back their bigger opponents into a
corner then spread out and surround
them the hyenas lower their hindquarters
to protect their most important assets
their
genitalia it's a defensive posture but
they've got an offensive weapon that
could be a
GameChanger a bite that's designed to
crush
bone this hyena has three sets of jaw
muscles powering 34 short broad teeth
that are set far back to maximize their
crushing
power his bite can exert a pressure of
over 21,000 lb per square in more than a
leopard or brown bear and enough to kill
a wild dog in a single bite without even
breaking its
skin but the dogs have a vicious bite
too and the power of the pack working
together they keep the hyenas
contained their success as Hunters is
because they cooperate like this
deciding the hyenas are no longer a
threat they retire for
lunch but one of the hyenas just won't
give up and the pack signal they're not
going to let it go so round two is
on the hyenas have a strong bite but
pound-for-pound the wild dogs is even
stronger and because hyenas are so
reliant on their sense of smell to
scavenge her nose is packed with
millions of nerve endings so that bite
has got to
hurt ring in pain she's now also
vulnerable to the rest of the
pack
when she finally twists free she can't
go
on she limps
away the dogs half her size get back to
their well-earned
feast wherever in the world there is
overpopulation competition is
ferocious and if you're a Hanuman Langer
monkey you'll use Jaws hands and gang
muscle to
win on the outskirts of jadur in
rajastan Monkey troops live by
Scavenging food discarded by the local
people but with numbers growing all the
time rival gangs battle for control of
the territory and its
food these newcomers want to take this
territory by force from the residents an
alpha male and his troop of wives and
babies lose this battle and the
residents will struggle to find enough
food to keep themselves and their babies
alive so they have everything to fight
for the battle starts with the newcomers
provoking the res residence in a deadly
game of
[Music]
tag then the invading alpha male takes
to the
field weighing up to 40 lb Hanuman
Langer males are larger than
females and their weapons are bigger too
nearly 1in long canines can bite through
an infant monkey's
skull the alpha male is claiming the
land for the
newcomers the females form the front
line of the resident's defense they have
the Home
Advantage the fight escalates into
allout
Warfare the newcomers attack but the
residents know the terrain and are a
finely tuned
team they Rush at the Invaders
their strategy is to cut off individuals
and overwhelm
them to feed their children they even
have to take on the alpha
male it's high risk but these mothers
are on a life or death
Mission the alpha male may be bigger but
he and his gang aren't fighting as a
coordinated unit working together the
residents break through Enemy
Lines
teamwork wins the
day and they drive the newcomers off
their
Turf but as the monkey populations grow
the competition for food will only get
more
ruthless when terrible danger lurks in
every shadow it takes speed agility and
the fighting skills of a martial arts
master just to make it through the
night in the Omani desert Middle East
temperatures can reach
120° and food sources are few and far
between the J calls this place
home at nearly a foot long from nose to
tail and weighing just 2 ounces he's
well adapted to life in the hot
spot his Keen sense of smell and acute
hearing means he can search for food in
the cool of the
night this Jer Hunter has a family to
feed more than 4 feet underground his
maid is keeping watch over a sleeping
brood of five babies it takes four weeks
for them to be able to fend for
themselves around round a quarter of Jer
babies don't make it this daddy must
Brave the dangers of the desert KN to
keep them
alive and he'll take on anyone that
stands in his way even a deadly horned
viper he uses his Speed and Agility to
twist himself free from the Viper
venomous
fangs but that's not the greatest threat
the daddy Faces tonight he's Gathering
seeds in the shadows when he senses
danger
lurking his opponent is another Jer come
to steal food from the mouths of his
children a wounded jerd could struggle
to survive so both Fighters give it
their
all the father uses the long bones and
large muscles of his hind legs to get
leverage under his
rival the Intruder bites the father's
tail his sharp teeth could inflict so
much damage it drops
off but The Escape Artist strikes
[Music]
again like scholen spers they clash in
midair jurs can jump more than 2 and 1
half times their body length that's like
a 6-ft man jumping 15 ft from a standing
start a woou style kick sends the father
flying but this acrobat lands Square on
his feet a perfect
he
regroups and uses all his strength to
pin the Intruder down with a bone
crunching pile
driver his opponent knows when he's
beaten he's had enough and cowers under
a
twig the acrobatic escape artist has put
his rival in his place and kept food on
his family's
table Yellowstone National
Park hunting ground for the baddest
animal fighters in North
America and arena for one of the
bloodiest long running battles on the
continent the Bison is the biggest
mammal on American
soil up to 6 feet tall weighing a cool
one
ton bison Bulls are Fierce Warriors
using violent showdowns to decide who
has the right to
breed but for the female of the species
the fight to secure the bloodline is a
matter of life or death bison Cavs have
only a 50/50 chance of surviving their
first year their mothers will use any
Force necessary to keep them
alive one of the bison's deadliest
enemies is the gray
wolf what the wolf lacks in size it
makes up for in speed and strategy
working together in packs to bring down
opponents 10 times its
size so when a pack of wolves meets a
lone Mama bison and her calf lives are
on the
line the pursuit is
on the bison's outnumbered 6 to one
surrounded she keeps her calf underneath
her using her vast size to protect it
from the circling wolves a wolf's number
one weapon is his
teeth he has 42 cutting blades that can
strip the flesh from a young bison calf
in
minutes and a bite pressure of5 100 lb
per square inch enough to crush a bison
calf's
skull but Mama bison has a mega weapon
too legs that are built to
kill her thigh muscles help power a kick
of nearly 4,000 lb in Force at the end
of each leg she has a 5in wide hoof a
toe covered with a hard layer of C
heran these missiles are so deadly they
can kill a wolf with a single
blow but this wolf seems to have nine
lives the wolves have numbers on their
side their strategy is to try to
distract the mother by harassing her
leaving her calf vulnerable to being
picked off by one or two
Hunters when the wolf grabs her baby it
looks like All Is Lost for
Mom but with the Cavalry here two lethal
hind legs are now
10 and for the Wolves consummate players
of the numbers game they know the
balance of the fight has turned against
[Music]
them
mom claims Victory she's kept her baby
alive for one more
[Music]
day